[Musique]
et voilà c'était l'image des présidents
de la République vu par les photographes
un très beau film réalisé par Guilain de
laaval et Aurélia BR et pour l'analyser
mais aussi pour aller un petit peu plus
loin nous avons le plaisir dans la Zone
d'Éducation documentaire d'accueillir
ellizabeth Pinot bonjour bonjour vous
êtes journaliste politique ancienne
présidente de l'Association de la presse
présidentielle et correspondante à
l'Élysée et à Matignon pour Reuters à
vos côté c'est alin génestar bonjour
vous êtes journal liste vous avez
participé à ce documentaire on vous
reconnaît d'ailleurs dans ce film vous
êtes l'ancien directeur de la rédaction
de Paris Match et vous avez créé en 2008
Polka magazine consacré à la
photographie ça tombe plutôt bien merci
à à tous les deux de répondre aux
questions de la classe enfin de deux
classes de Première du lycée Paul enevin
bonjour les élèves bonjour alors vous
avez énormément travaillé je sais que
vous avez plein de questions à à poser à
nos à nos invités qui nous donneront
peut-être des secrets de leur de leur
métier ça sera en fonction de en
fonction de vos questions mais d'abord
je voulais moi vous poser quelques
questions si là je vous demande une
photo une image du président Emmanuel
Macron laquelle vous vient tout de suite
en tête oui avec ton chien avec sa femme
à la victoire de sa présidentielle il
était sur le le podium et il avait levé
la main en l'air OK dans son bureau oui
pendant la Coupe du Monde ah la coupe du
mondeok la photo qui est dans toutes les
mairies j'ai une autre image qui me
vient en tête celle où il porte un site
à
capuche vous l'avez pas cette image en
tête ah ah tu peux m'en parler tu la
vois cette image oui mais j'ai entendu
dire que c cétait un montage pas que
c'était un montage ah ou ok intéressant
disnous tu voulais tu voulais participer
chose ça a été créé par une intelligence
artificielle ah bon ah bon tu es sûr de
ça ouais je suis sûr com ben non moi moi
je peux te dire que non je je je parle
sous votre contrôle he mais
non en effit mais c'est intéressant que
vous y pensiez non non c'est c'est c'est
une vraie image donc le président a
voulu montrer de lui une image un peu
plus jeune j'imagine avec un un sweite
et un site et une capuche quelle est la
photo vous avez préféré dans le film
dans le documentaire que vous avez
regardé quelle est la photo qui vous a
le plus marqué surpris
choqué dites-moi
oui la photo de Jack SHAC dans l'avion
ouais quand il aass
croisé sur le siège de devant avec des
chaussons ouais ok pourquoi pourquoi ça
t'a qu'est-ce que ça ça te fait penser à
quoi cette photo quand je le vois comme
ça je me dis qu'il est détendu c'est un
boss OK et moi j'aimerais bien être
comme lui ok la photo de Nicolas Sarkozi
bah en tenue de sport ah ah oui quand il
monte les Mar quand il monte les marches
de de l'Élysée pourquoi elle t'a marqué
cette photo bah parce que c'est un
Président il est censé être en costard
et tout mais là il ten d'espoir ok mais
tu trouves ça bien ou pas bien qu'il est
laissé faire cette photo bien pourquoi
bah parce que ça montre qu'il est comme
les autres malgré qu'il soit président
d'accord ben je vous propose qu'on passe
maintenant à vos questions merci
beaucoup déjà pour ce pour ce retour sur
ce film quelle est la plus belle image
que vous ayez publié parmi les
présidents et pourquoi une image de
François mitteran avec
edmoud colle quand ils se sont
recueillis en mémoire des des victimes
et de l'Holocauste et c'était une image
très forte et on est content quand on
arrive à travers ces images a montré la
vérité des personnages moi ce que j'aime
c'est excuse-moi ce que j'aime c'est
voir les gens en vrai moi j'aime les
voir en vrai donc moi j'ai commencé
l'Élysée à la fin de Chirac puis il y a
eu Nicolas Sarkozi nouvelle ère c'était
le on avait quitté un président en
cravate on retrouvait un président qui
grimpait 4 à qu en jogging les marches
de l'Élysée tu as parlé de cette photo
puis ensuite on a eu François Hollande
le président normal et puis ensuite
Emmanuel Macron et ces personnes par
exemple François Hollande Nicolas
Sarkozi Emmanuel Macron je les ai vu
avant qu'il devienne président et ça
vraiment j'adore c'est-à-dire voir cette
ambition ces personnes qui veulent
devenir président voilà Nicolas Sarkozi
était ministre de l'intérieur on sentait
qu'il en avait déjà envie Emmanuel
Macron c'était le conseiller de François
Hollande que je voyais presque tous les
jours on allait lui poser des questions
sur la politique du président et puis un
jour la question de devenir président
lui-même se poser et j'aime beaucoup
voir cette évol
moi j'aime bien les voir tous les jours
presque tous les jours en tout cas
souvent en vrai et et pouvoir côtoyer ce
ce pouvoir et ce désir de pouvoir à
venir parfois parce qu'il peut y avoir
maintenant des candidats pour la
prochaine présidence bien
sûr moi j'ai une question pour Alain
génestar est-ce que toutes les photos
sont mises en scène oui a priori et
notre métier ça consiste parfois à
briser la la cette mise en scène oui a
priori parce que parce qu'ils sont
présidents de la République euh parce
que ils ont une image publique qu'ils
veulent contrôler à nous si on participe
à cette mise en scène de nous arranger
pour que cette mise en scène donne le
vrai du personnage je cité tout à
l'heure la la photo de Chirac dans son
avion il sait qu'il est en communication
et qu'il y a un photographe qui est là
et qui va le prendre en photo mais
malgré tout cette image est naturelle et
pourquoi elle est naturelle parce qu'il
se
entre le photographe et le la personne
photographiée une sorte de complicité
naturelle que à un certain moment
l'homme politique futtil président lâche
la garde et se met dans une situation
d'être un homme comme les autres et de
piquer un petit roupillon dans la vie là
on arrive justement à même s'il y a une
mise en scène au départ à cassé cette ce
contrôle de l'image alors pour bien
comprendre les présidents ils ont un
service de commun communication tous les
présidents ont un service de
communication et ils sont présidents ils
sont en représentation c'est pour ça qu'
qu'ils veulent montrer une certaine
image les séquences les déplacements
sont préparés à chaque fois qu'on fait
un déplacement on sait où va aller le
président son équipe a regarder si le
décor était bien correspondait au thème
du jour si c'est l'écologie si c'est
l'industrie voilà tout cela est très
préparé et quand on est journaliste on
est là pour voir et dire ce qui se fait
l'Élysée aimerait bien qu'on dise ce
qu'ils ont préparé et ce qu'ils ont
envie que qu'on dise mais nous on dit ce
qui se passe réellement et c'est valable
également pour les photographes les
photographes ils sont journalistes ils
prennent une photo qui justement et je
reviens à ce que tu disais tout à
l'heure une photo de journaliste n'est
pas une photo trafiquée par par
l'intelligence artificielle c'est toute
la base du journalisme le journalisme
c'est le fait c'est on est là il se
passe quelque chose on dit ce qu'il se
passe vraiment et pas ce que l'Élysée
veut que l'on dise on dit tel que les
choses se passent et puis en ce qui me
concerne on pose les questions qu'on a
envie de poser que les Français se pose
à travers nous et qu'on pose au
président et ça ne plaît pas forcément à
l'Élysée mais donc il y a un petit
rapport de force qui est très ça c'est
ça la démocratie c'est des choses
préparées par les présidents les
ministres les les élus du peuple et puis
les journalistes qui disent tel que les
choses se passent et le disent au au
lecteurs que vous êtes voilà Sonia
pourquoi les photos privées des
présidents intéressent toujours les
lecteurs contrairement aux photos
classiques comme le sommet du G20
parce que on est sans arrêt en recherche
de naturel alors là vous allez me dire
oui mais quand vous faites des photos de
la vie privée d'un président de la
République c'est quand même en général
pas toujours mais en général c'est avec
son accord c'est à T heure c'est dans
tel endroit voilà on est on est convoqué
et on peut prendre tel genre de photo et
c'est là que on peut peut-être espérer
qu'à un moment il baisse la garde qu'à
un moment voilà il soit vraiment dans sa
cuisine et non pas qu' il est l'idée de
se faire photographier dans la cuisine
et on le fait parce que le public vous
d'autres lecteurs d'autres
téléspectateurs aspire à cela c'est une
question qui a été assez récurrente dans
dans dans dans vos interrogations la vie
privée pourquoi la vie privée moi ça m'a
étonné que vous ayez ce regard là vous
qui avez tous vous avez tous un
téléphone tous ce que ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que vous avez donc
tous accès aux réseaux sociaux je dis
pas de bêtises sur Instagram sur TikTok
sur tout ça d'accord
pourquoi je trouve ça dingue que ça vous
étonne de la part d'autres que que des
générations avant vous se posent la
question parce qu'ils n'avaient pas
accès à la vie privée des uns et des
autres je l'entends mais que vous qui
avez accès à à la vie privée de vos
camarades dans un cercle très restreint
et puis même vous pouvez voir la vie
privée des stars la vie privée jusqu'aux
personnalités politiqu c'est marrant que
cette question revienne ça pourquoi ça
vous choc que les présidents ils se
montrent avec bah leurs chemise ouverte
en train de faire la cuisine en train de
faire du sport alors que vous-même oui
ah ben ça alors ça c'est super on va
vous prendre tous un par un Robin au
fond on va partir du fond vas-y Robin
dis-moi c'est c'est surprenant parce que
même des politiques pour nous ils sont
peut-être pas comme nous si je peux dire
ouais font en vrai pas si différent ok
un président c'est censé être
celui qui représente la France du coup
ça doit être tout écré en fait du coup
d'ord donc il mange pas il a pas
d'enfant il a pas non mais si il peut
manger tout ça mais il doit être
présentable en gros ah ouais en fait ils
se sont tellement construit une image
que du coup fait ça s'est joué contre
eux en fait et du coup en fait on pense
qu'ils sont pas comme nous alors qu'en
fait si c'est ça en fait ils ont
tellement montré des photos de en
chemise plutôt qu'en t-shirt que bah du
coup nous quand on pense à un Président
on pense pas un président on pe un
président en chemise je trouve que on va
prendre plus la personne en chemise au
sérieux que c en T-shirt très bien c on
verra ça au prochain
candidat pour la prochaine élection non
mais vous êtes les électeurs de demain
moi ma question s'adresse à Élisabeth
Pinot donc pouvez-vous poser n'importe
quelle question ou alors o vont dit les
sujets et les thèmes à aborder
alors oui on peut poser toutes les
questions mais en général alors déjà
est-ce qu'il y a des conférences de
presse est-ce que le président est
ouvert avec la presse ça tous les
présidents ne sont pas à la même
enseigne sur ce point-là par exemple
François Hollande était très ouvert avec
la presse il parlait nous parlait
souvent à la fin des voyages voyez quand
il vit visiter une école comme ici on
pouvait lui parler un petit peu à la fin
à la fin de la visite ce qui est pas du
tout le cas d'Emmanuel Macron par
exemple qui fait très peu de grandes
conférences de presse les conférences de
presse c'est à la fin de des voyages
après les conseils de Bruxelles donc en
général on pose les questions
d'actualité c'est-à-dire les questions
qui qui des choses qui se sont passées
ce le jour même voilà c'est c'est en
général ce ce ce qu'on pose comme
question il arrive que l'Élysée veuille
savoir il nous demande vousz
l'interroger sur quoi pour préparer un
peu certains le disent la plupart ne le
disent pas et le président et notamment
enfin est préparé pour avoir réponse à
tout comment vous expliquez cette
distinction justement entre un président
très fermé à la presse c'est un
président très ouvert et et qu'est-ce
que ça change qu'est-ce que ça dit ah
bah le le le rapport n'est pas le même
c'est sûr que François Hollande il il le
disait lui-même il disait moi je je fais
pas de différence entre les journalistes
et les Français voilà et puis mais ça
lui a servi ou pas alors ça l'a plutôt
desservi c'està-d que voilà c'est là
vous voulez renir c'est quelqu'un qui
était proche de la presse et finalement
il n'a pas pu se représenter à la fin de
son quinquena parce que son image était
très dégradée il avait peur que
l'extrême droite prenne le pouvoirfà
donc il a il a préféré ne pas se
représenter et ça Emmanuel Macron qui
était son conseiller l'a très bien
observé tous les jours à l'Élysée donc
je pense que quand il est arrivé il a
dit avec moi ça se passera pas comme ça
et d'ailleurs il a voulu fermer la salle
de presse de l'Élysée tout de suite et
après 2 ans de combat et j'étais
président de la presse présidentielle à
l'époque on a réussi à la sauver j'ai
une question pour àing et c'est pourquoi
prendre les publier des clichers gênants
comme par exemple un président à Laam en
C de bain je je vais te répondre
différemment pourquoi j'ai pas publié
une photo de Jacques Chirac non pas en
slip de bain mais en slip il était en
train de regarder à sa fenêtre au fort
de brillançon euh sa fenêtre qui
visiblement était une fenêtre de salle
de bain il regardait la mer et puis
devait y avoir quelque chose sur la mer
qui l'intéressait donc il avait des
jumelles et là il y avait un paparad
avec un objectif comme ça qui a pris la
photo du président de la République en
train de regarder de sa salle de bain en
slip j'ai vu la photo l' porté à Paris
Match parce que on s dit pas paradis
s'est dit je vais gagner un petit peu
d'argent euh j'ai bloqué la photo
c'està-dire bloqué la photo c'est je
l'ai acheté mais pour ne pas la publier
pour la mettre dans un coin le Canard
Enchaîné a appris que j'avais refusé de
publier la photo le Canard Enchaîné a
fait un petit article en disant alain
genesta a refuser de publier une photo
du président en slip j'ai appelé le
directeur de can enchaîné je dit mais
pourquoi veux-tu que Paris Match publie
une photo du président de la République
Enel quelle est l'information et comment
va-t-on 15 jours après demander au
président de la République une grande
interview sur l'avenir du monde alors
qu'on se sera moqué de lui qu'on l'aura
qu'on aura dégradé son image et j'ai dit
au directeur du Canar enchaîné puisque
l'audace pour toi c'est en gros de faire
n'importe quoi cette photo je l'ai et si
tu veux tu peux la publier bon ilclatédé
a pas publiieré la photo de toute façon
jeurais jeaurais jamais donné c'était un
jeu entre nous tout ça pour dire qu'on
fait pas n'importe quoi tout ce qu'on
vient de dire sur la vie privée on
respecte la vie privée de toutes les
personnes et notamment des présidents de
la République mais ça veut pas dire
qu'on a pas envie d'entrouvrir la porte
de voir certaines choses à condition
qu'elle soit signifiante c'estàdire
qu'elle nous montre la vérité une part
de la vérité de cet homme politique mais
la vie la vie privée pour la vie privée
jamais et des photos qui pourrai mettre
un homme tique dans une
situation humiliante désavantageuse
ingrate on évite de le faire parce que
tout simplement parce qu'on est à la
fois on est correct dans la vie il faut
être correct conseil que je vous donne
j'ai l'âge pour vous donner ce genre de
conseil et puis après ensuite ça se
retourne contre nous parce que toutes
les portes vont se fermer pas les portes
du privé mais toutes les portes même du
public on pourra plus jamais rien faire
avec cet homme politique on est des
médiateurs on est là pour apporter des
informations pour certes publier des
textes intéressants mais pour publier
aussi et diffuser des photos
signifiantes est-ce que vous voyez une
différence entre vos entretiens avec des
hommes politiques et des entretiens avec
des femmes politiques et bien non pas
vraiment à la différence que comme il y
a pas de femme présidente de la
République et bien je n'ai pas eu
l'occasion de parler à une femme
présidente de la République donc on
verra le jour où ça arrivera ça arrivera
peut-être un jour on a eu des femmes qui
l'ont voulu l'être he c'est goen royal
on a eu Martine auri on y a pensé donc
peut-être que maintenant qu'il y a plus
de femmes en
politiqueécquement va arriver mais non
je ne fais pas de différence non
interroger une après comme je suis une
femme il peut peut-être y avoir une un
peu de sororité mais c'est c'est c'est
bien malgré moi donc je ne fais pas de
différence you on t'écoute qu'est-ce
qu'une photo parfaite comment se
construire une photo pour qu'elle soit
parlante et non pas juste une image
figée photo parfaite c'est la photo qui
qui dit tout c'est la photo qui se tient
toute seule qui a pas besoin de titre
c'est la photo qui peut venir en
couverture avec juste le logo du du
magazine poulka Paris Match et la photo
ditit tout euh moi j'ai participé à une
photo
parfaite c'était à hwiit
birkenao j'avais proposé à Simon veille
de venir avec moi à birkonao et elle
elle a accepté c'était début janvier
2005 pour les 60 ans de la libération du
camp et on arrive il y avait un ép
brouillard et on a traversé le le
brouillard il faisait presque Mo- 10
faisait très froid il y avait personne
dans le camp et on voyait rien les seuls
qui savaient que la la voie ferit qui
rentrait dans le camp elle était là
juste à à côté de nous et à un moment le
ciel s'est dégagé le soleil a éclairé
comme au cinéma vous a éclairé tous la
petite cohorte qui avancé le le long de
la voie et on a vu cette voix et j'ai
dit à Simon veille il faudrait prendre
une photo de vous sur la voie parce que
c'est l'endroit où derrière on voit
l'entrée du camp vous savez cette
célèbre tour en forme de clocheton les
trains passés dessous avec les rails et
me dit non parce que ces rails sont
sacrés parce que ces rails ont porté les
trains où tant de centaines de milliers
de personnes sont mortes on visite tout
le camp et on revient vers les rails et
elle voulait vraiment témoigner on
s'approche des rails et je lui dis Simon
veille maintenant c'est le moment je
suis ému quand j'en parle parce que
cette photo fallait vraiment que je la
fasse c'était mon métier de faire cette
photo c'était mon métier non pas de la
forcer mais de la convaincre que si elle
était là il fallait faire ce genre
d'image cette image on l' mis en
couverture de mage et c'est c'est la
photo parfaite c'est la photo qui dit
tout qui raconte l'histoire qui respecte
qui a un regard et qui fait que les gens
vont se sentir concernés et vont et vont
lire le témoignage formidable et très
émouvant qu'il y avait derrière
qu'est-ce que vous pensez des photos
retouchées qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
quand on enlève une ride par-ci un petit
un petit bout de gras par là oui disnous
nanama je trouve que ça enlève un peu le
naturel du du président parce que on s
on sent pas la la réalité du vrai
personnage on se dit juste que c'est
quelqu'un qui a fait une photo et qu'on
a retouché donc c'est pas la même
personne en vrai que dans une photo
alors est-ce qu'il vous arrive est-ce
qu'il vous est arrivé qu'on vous demande
des retouches ah ouou c'est pas c'est
c'est c'est fréquent ah et mais vous
êtes pas forcé de dire oui quand on
prend une
photo on s'arrange pour ne pas mettre la
personne photographier en désavantage
dans son désavantage on s'arrange pour
utiliser des lumières qui soient pas
frontal qui donne pas 10 ans de de plus
donc quand il y a une photo comme ça
c'est une forme d'arrangement que de
préparer déjà des des filtres et ce
qu'il ne faut jamais faire moi c'est
toujours interdit de le faire apka c'est
une religion on ne touche jamais au
corps d'une personne on lui coupe pas
une oreille on lui allonge pas les les
oreilles on lui enlève pas un bourlet
comme ça a pu se faire dans Paris
Match après moi je dis ça parce que si
ça avait été moi j'aurais j'aura refusé
donc match a fait une erreur c'est pas
un crime pas grandchose c'est du Zè
d'ailleurs je parle de Nicolas Sarkozy
Nicolas SARC n'a jamais demandé qu'on
lui enlève un bourlet tous les hommes
quand ils sont un peu comme ça ils ont
des bourl
donc c'est du Zè mais c'est idiot faire
de zel et tu as parfaitement raison
retoucher une photo c'est mentir on peut
arranger le décor on peut estomper les
choses on doit rien enlever du décor on
doit non plus rien rajouter surtout en
ce moment par tout à l'heure des des des
photos d'intelligence artificielle du
fait des fake news on se doit d'être
encore plus
authentiqueavant on doit toujours être
authentique mais là ça doit être
vraiment une je disais pour Poka c'est
une religion mais ça doit s'imposer on
ne doit pas toucher à une photo dans le
reportage dans le film dans le
documentaire il y a y a une séquence sur
les paparazzad vous l'avez d'accord
c'est c'est ces photographes qui se
mettent un petit peu on l'a un petit peu
évoqué voilà qui se met dans un coin
très discret et qui volle des photos
d'accord avant de de de poser la
question à nos invités je voulais savoir
ce que vous vous en pensez est-ce que
c'est grave est-ce que ça vous choque
qu'est-ce que vous trouvez qu'au
contraire heureusement qu'ils sont là
pour nous donner ce qu'ils ne veulent
pas par ailleurs nous donner Serena euh
moi je trouve que parfois c'est grave
dans le sens où comme les présidents les
présidents aussi c'est des humains ils
ont une vie privée et c'est pas tout qui
doit être exposé et je trouve que çaen
fait trop parfois et ça peut vraiment
salir l'image d'un président ok d'autres
ont un un avis différent en vrai c'est
pas bien de ce qu'ils font parce qu'ils
prennent des photos ça leur demander
l'autorisation h HM mais après il y a
des gens quand ils ontus ont dit c'est
pas bien parce qu'après ça donne une
mauvaise image des présidents mais si le
président il fait ça dans son intimité
c'est son image réelle ça veut dire ce
qu'ils font d'un côté c'est pas bien
mais ils montre la vérité ça veut dire
c'est bien un peu mais pas trop pour
pour le lecteur en tout cas pour celui
qui voit la l'image ça peut dire quelque
chose on a on arrête avec toi nanama
dis-nous euh moi je pense que à du tu es
un personnage politique je trouve que
que tu as signé pour pour être une
personne publique c'està dire que c'est
vrai que à partir du à partir du moment
où tu es politicien du coup on a le
droit de tout prendre à n'importe quel
moment parce que c'est les conséquences
de d'être une personne publique du coup
moi je voulais savoir si il n'y avait
que la paparazade qui vous permettait
vous de vous approcher de la vérité non
non la paparazade en fait partie euh ce
que tu lui as dit c'est très bien
personnage politique c'est un personnage
public public ça veut dire un jardin
public personnage public euh les
Paparadis et d'autres prennent parfois
des des photos sans autorisation de ces
personnages publics en l'occurrence les
présidents de la République dans des
lieux
accessible si on rentre à l'intérieur de
d'une maison privée pour ne pas dire
dans la chambre à coucher euh là c'est
pas c'est c'est ça ne doit pas se faire
euh toutes les images de PAP parasie que
moi j'ai pu publier j'en ai publié
beaucoup c'est des c'est des
photographies prises à l'extérieur sans
l'autorisation de la personne et c'est
là qu'intervient ce que nous sommes et
ce que nous voulons continuer d'être si
vous êtes dans un grand journal et que
vous êtes souvent en relation avec un un
personnage un président de la République
même si vous avez des photos de
Paparadis qui le montrerai dans une
situation très désavantageuse vous les
publiez pas donc en général c'est des
c'est des photos où il y a une prise de
risque de notre part parce que la loi
nous interdit de le faire et la loi
quand c'est président de la République
ça peut être assez fort mais on n pas de
problème si ça montre effectivement don
d'abord on est correct par rapport à
nous-même parce que on dévoile une une
vérité on dévoile une information ou
c'est simplement quelque chose d'
anecdotique qui peut faire un peu
sourire de voir un président de la
République en train de faire ses courses
en train de faire du vélo ou je ne sais
quoi mais ça fait partie oui ça fait
partie des des des images qui
contribuent à ce que nous recherchons
c'estàdire la nature le naturel la
vérité et ça peut aussi conduire à à
quelques
ennuis judiciaires ou professionnels
mais voilà on accepte ou pas de le faire
c'est une prise de risque importante que
de faire ça on continue avec toi petit
Jean euh quelle est aujourd'hui pour
vous la principale difficulté dans votre
métier de journaliste bah sans hésiter
l'arrivée du téléphone portable et
d'Internet et du smartphone et des des
réseaux sociaux moi je pu comparer parce
que j'ai connu les deux sous Jacques
Chirac il n'y avait pas ça ù c'était le
début et tout ça est arrivé en même
temps que Nicolas Sarkozi et ça a
complètement changé non seulement la
présidence et mais mais aussi notre
travail de journaliste maintenant avant
on avait les choses sur tous les agences
on avait les choses en premier on les
annonçait au reste du monde maintenant
c'est souvent les choses arrivent en
tweet on est doublé des informations
son paraissent nous il faut qu'on a
temps de les vérifier c'est comme ça que
c'est c'est la différence entre le
journalisme et une information non
vérifiée donc voilà ça bouleverse
complètement en terme de de rapidité et
de et
voilà distinguer le vrai du faux
distinguer ce qui a été fait par un
journaliste ou ce qui a été fait par
l'intelligence artificielle c'est le
défi d'aujourd'hui et de demain
incontestablement très bonne question on
continue avec Amine c'est pour Alain
gestar regrettez-vous une photo si oui
laquelle et
pourquoi oui
oui cétait pas bien ça euh Jacques
Chirac président euh 2e mandat donc
vieillissant et à un moment euh on
parlait de la santé des présidents
et à un moment on voyait bien quand on
posait les questions fallait poser la
question fort et puis euh donc il s'est
fait équiper d'un d'un appareil auditif
et là j'ai fait une chose qu'il faut pas
faire c'est-à-dire euh j'ai demandé à un
photographe lors d'une conférence de
presse de se mettre légèrement de côté
de zoomer et de mon après ça va pareil
c'est pas correct et on l'a publié dans
match le titre c'était le président à
l'écoute des Français bon peu douteux
donc ce genre de chose c'est des
tentations parfois on a des tentations
et on subit à la tentation mais non j'ai
même appelé le président pour pour
m'excuser d' d'une décision que j'avais
prise mais on t'écoute est-ce que le
métier de journaliste a changé votre
personnalité
je pense pas que qu'il a changé ma
personnalité je pense qu'il a exacerbé
l'enthousiasme que j'avais voilà je
pense que ça m'intéresse toujours autant
et je c'est tellement intéressant que
chaque jour est plus enthousiasment que
la veille voilà donc je pense que ça
amplifié le désir de faire ce métier le
désir d'écrire le désir de voir des
choses et je vous souhaite à tous
d'avoir un métier que ce soit boulanger
ou écrivain qui vous intéresse autant
que que que ce métier et et que vous
ayez autant de plaisir à faire chaque
jour et rien de venir ici vous voyez ça
je ne VIè des bois je suis pas certaine
d'être déjà venu je suis contente de
vous voir vos questions m'intéressent
énormément vous voyez quand quand je
vais quand je vais voir le le Président
je vais penser à ce qui vous intéresse
enfin c'est c'est voilà là on apprend là
là ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui c'est c'est
c'est pas de journalisme à proprement
parler mais on on ça me nourrit en tant
que journaliste incontestablement euh on
continue avec ça sera l'avant-dernière
question de là-bas c'est ça c'est toi
pardon excuse-moi question pour
allangénestor qu'est-ce que vous
pourriez dire à un jeune qui voudrait
exercer votre métier fais-le just do
it si vous avez une curiosité de la vie
si vous voulez savoir ce qu'il y a au
fond du jardin et puis passer dans le
jardin d'à côté et puis aller plus loin
à l'autre bout du monde rencontrer des
gens une dernière question d'Abdel il
est où Abdel il est tout là-bas si vous
pouviez rencontrer une personnalité
historique envie ou décédé qui
choisirez-vous et
pourquoi je sais pas je je
réfléchisi je sais pas pourquoi je vous
réponds Napoléon je sais pas pourquoi
j'ai dit ça mais voilà je je Napoléon à
roi de France par exemple c'est c'est
très ancien mais comme je m'intéresse
aux personnes de pouvoir ce serait quoi
la première question ah bah pourquoi
pourquoi tout ça pourquoi que que
faites-vous là Napoléon pourquoi
pourquoi tout tout pourquoi ce ce ce
parcours oui vraiment je voilà c'est
c'est c'est le premier personnage qui me
vient à l'esprit star merci ça m'a
permis de réfléchir moi je vais aller
encore plus loin je dirais Cléopâtre
pourquoi benah je vourais vérifier la
longueur de son
nez et
puis prendre une photo de avec
César euh sachant sachant qu'après il y
avait marcanttoine donc en plus c'est un
feuilleton un reportage complet
voir si vraiment cette relation on
parlait tout à l'heure de vousvez pas
prononcé le mot mais de de de people ou
Mo de photo privé cette
rencontre Cléopâtre César vous rendez
compte la dimension des personnages
historique qu'est-ce qui s'est passé on
sait qu'il y a eu un petit bébé qui
s'appelait Césarion qui est devenu aussi
pharaon mais est-ce que ça a changé les
les relation de Rome avec l'Égypte voilà
en terme de d'aventure amoureuse et de
géopolitique ça me semble ça ferait une
belle une ça ferait une belle une belle
couverture ouais je signale Alain gestar
que le dernier numéro de poulka on vous
en fait don enfin c'est surtout Alain
génestar qui vous en fait don pour votre
CDI il y a trois exemplaires n'hésitez
pas à les consulter et en parler aussi
autour de vous partout partout dans le
lycée comme ça vous trouverez des
informations et surtout de très très
très belles photos merci infiniment à
tous les deux d'avoir participé à Z la
Zone d'Éducation documentaire merci
aussi à vous les é pour vos questions
brillantes pertinentes qui ont été
préparées par vos professeurs qu'on
remercie aussi beaucoup elles vous ont
très très très bien préparé pour cette
émission et puis nous on se retrouve
très vite avec une nouvelle classe et un
nouveau documentaire parce qu'il n'y a
pas d'âge pour questionner le monde et
ses images salut les
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
élève